first of all yard games and i'll be
honest with you as a gateway to
homosexuality dog
it can be yeah okay let's play right
here you get a
few bears deep you start winning your
boy start hugging
yeah oh i can't believe you made that
shot your shirts are off
[Laughter]
[Music]
get your life together
it's scary out there you still doing jiu
jitsu in uh nashville yeah man i got a
one strike
oh congrats dude that's a big deal you
look like you moan during jiu jitsu
only a little man why steve always go
ass down face up
only if the guy's handsome
that's hilarious brennan looks like he
has to what's that thing you have to use
when you have to start your car with
that blow thing
oh that's alcohol the breathalyzer yeah
that blow starter
brandon looks like he'll [ __ ] blow
start a starburst right now in that
[ __ ] shirt
no this shirt looks like a blow start a
bunch of dudes
brennan looks like they gotta get like
asked you to put one hand on his belly
when he farts
dude that's crazy dude
fred brennan looks like the kind of guy
you tell him hey i made something for
you put your hand on my stomach and you
fart
but he falls for it again and again
every time dude
i made something for you what are you 12
god man yeah yeah this whole [ __ ]
show is 12.
are you kidding me we had that chatty
artist in here
was he on all the adderall what's going
on there dudes like
oh i painted this on uh on adderall
he showed me some of his other art it's
just drawings of adderall
they described what he wants to do next
yeah one of them he
chiseled adderall into pieces of stone
i'm like this is
insane and i looked at his girl she was
like this
one of his paintings was just draw he
drew a bunch of words
[Laughter]
he's a chatty cathy usually artists
aren't that chatty man
usually they're really silent and they
wear something introverted
like a cape or something i think
something yeah maybe some a face mask of
some sort
yeah bracelets lots of braces yeah
bracelets a lot of uh
some of you'll just see them wearing
like a rumor on their body yeah a lot of
them they look like they're styled by
jeremy piven
yeah very ava bracelets very avant-garde
dude
what do we got going on here today man
gang gang bro
we've got some people waiting to talk to
us uh do we want to talk to some people
on zoom
i want to talk to chin it's only been
120 episodes to try and get into a
conversation with it
i know nothing about chin is this one
twenty one twenty wow wow
damn 120 since day one two hundred bunch
and twenty that's crazy it's once a week
windows 120 weeks
it sounds like a [ __ ] ton it's 52 weeks
in a year four years isn't it
wow it's a little too over two and a
quarter a year two eleven two and a
quarter years
there's a little too much cream in your
[ __ ] coffee though boy
that's you you know how i know you like
dick how much cream you have in your
coffee
because i don't like no dick boy
i like dick dog i'll tell you if i saw
somebody else's dick dude i would be
shocked
you think yeah man you think i'm seeing
somebody's dick you're crazy dog
you've never been a lot you don't get in
that jiu jitsu locker room after moaning
all goddamn
practice i don't want to go play a game
for two hours to have an excuse to go
look at man's at night yeah that's fair
or daytime because a lot of kickers are
like that
yeah it's usually the kickers dog i
could have been a kicker i could have
been a [ __ ] uh
probably good referee i think no you
look like a long snapper you do
you do my friend cam canada is a long
snapper in the league or pittsburgh yeah
oh damn how good of a friend i hate when
people say friend how good a friend we
talking about here
buddy thank you for being honest
i hate it when people say that too yeah
like chin's a buddy
huh you know i've known chin for seven
minutes
it's hard to get to friend with asian
because they it's such a
limited you don't get a lot of
and this is the only reason i would ever
beat an asian and i'm going to be real
honest and we're going to just get a
reaction out of them
to get some information out of them
yes but what if they don't speak english
that's all right
they speak english dude if you beat him
enough no
i'll i'll roll the street that's too
much i'll roll i'll roll the streets and
bring a translator
dude i'll drop him off at a vfw and let
those old boys beat him up you know
you know what i'm saying let next
grandfather beat him up
i'll drop him off at an american legion
nick looks like he saw his shadow too
yeah nick were you on a bender all night
dude
why do you look like this i don't know i
don't know actually you just woke up
that way
it's a really it's a really bad length
of my beard right now
uh no you look real pale too yeah i
don't know
i don't know you weren't doing stuff
last night
he looks like like he should host a show
called between two urns
it does not look you look like you you
look like you passed out in a lake and
then walked into [ __ ] work
i'm so glad this camera's black and
white you can't tell oh no it'll pick it
up
yeah it ain't that tight jason voorhees
younger brother kind of right now and no
offense nick you look like a handsome
guy he's got beautiful blue eyes but
he um yeah you just look like you
definitely slept in the dryer
i caught it i caught myself as i left
the bathroom i'm like i'm about to go on
camera that's crazy hopefully they don't
notice
yeah i wouldn't even go on drawing
without looking like that
yeah i wouldn't even have stevie wiebe
draw you man right now man
i put it up on my wall yo i love that
hall of fame art man that's that before
picture
yeah nick nick looks like he's been
zooming with his dad all night
we were hashing some stuff out
we have issues to work through man yeah
crazy man so does this guy though look
at this is tristan what's his name oh
oh wow what's up you little sugar
hookers
i understand it for you well he's about
to die at home tattoos
gang gang about to get that rat king
right now
on himself too did he did that himself
brendan you're going on my butt
that's an honor that's an honor
because when them boys are pounding it
out they're going to see my face oh
it's going to be dope yeah you just did
it that means advertised you're talking
about
gay stuff i'll tell you right now and
i'm getting my sleeve on my leg done
nothing hurts more than your leg with
tattoos really oh
dude i can take some i've been through
some [ __ ] in my life fighting grown men
in a steel cage in my underwear that
hurts
getting a tattoo on your leg [ __ ]
hurts
really oh think about doing some drugs
in austin when i get it done
i heard a little zany helps out little
zany why are you licking your lips
because i can't wait i'm scaring
everybody sorry man i'm sorry
i'm sorry man um that guy
does he have the wrecking tattoo yeah
that was his leg that's a dope ass
that's why you know you made it dog
that's incredible man um
first of all thanks for getting the
tattoo that's a good
good one too that thing's dope yeah
that's nice looking
would get that tattoo yeah thanks for
getting the tattoo and yeah make sure uh
make sure you keep it clean oh here's
andrew santino he's probably complaining
about
here's andrew what do you do babies
what's up playboy
what's up dog not too much how's it
going how's it going
we're hanging in there man he was
driving too
where are you driving to brother you
going to work some people got to work
amen daddy what type of um uh
field are you in are you you do what
type of stuff land or something
uh plumbing plumbing company yeah okay
wonderland
yeah yeah laying that pipe you know what
i mean yo
underground arts where are you calling
him from doug uh
san antonio texas oh oh yeah yes sir
hotel emma baby that's my [ __ ] we tried
to come see you brendan but uh
got canceled a few times because of
covid and then you got kovid
yeah i got it i
yeah i ate a couple sleazy churros yeah
you ate lion brother yeah that's that
you know i see
churros yeah i look at churros like theo
looks like cocaine
i see it i will [ __ ] snort the [ __ ]
out of a churro yeah
thankfully churro is coming that line
bro that's how i like them
yeah when the churros you can't get them
broken up i hate that
or when they're too stiff oh yeah i like
that soft turtle
yeah sure i mean nobody believes
however you like your churro that's how
you like your churro man
yeah vernon likes i get brendan likes to
bring likes to chew his churro up
and then take it out of his mouth and
try to remake it on his plate
and he calls him churros he's the kind
of guy brennan's more like the kind of
guy who doesn't take the wrapper off a
stick of butter before eating it as a
snack
oh yeah true that man i'll eat this
butter is not a candy bar we're okay i
wish it was man
what do you got for us brother oh uh
what i got for you
is i got a debate club for you
which one would y'all rather do would
y'all rather party with them country
boys at the ranch or ranch rager
or would you hang out would you rather
hang out with the real ogs in an inner
city strip club
oh we talking like magic city in atlanta
and like ti's there
drugging [ __ ] and stuff or and then
the ranch are we talking more like
chappelle's dad's there
oh okay yeah you talking about that big
big cave big ferg look and let's also
recognize the guy
also tries to play real hard his name is
also kevin it's kevin okay
you know what i'm saying now now let's
also let's just
put it down to the nit and gritty here
what he's asking was you rather party
with black guys or white guys
okay that's what's going on here and
that's fine um
i think mine it would just be i would go
like i think the strip club is just such
an unsafe environment i feel like you're
gay
it's such a pink eye i just don't want
to risk pink guy
you know i know you're gay yeah you're
scared of strip clubs
oh dude i think it's disgusting their
asses are in your face
and they're rubbing their big tits it's
just too much for me man
i'd rather hang out with the boys on the
ranch yeah dude
the ranch first of all the ranch has
some nice chicks dude ranch dressing who
loves ranch dressing
[ __ ] dog that's right yeah you right
buddy all right
[ __ ] condiment johnson over here
loves his
way around a [ __ ] half a tub of zat
ziki as well okay you know what i'm
saying
ranch deal's the only guy in his strip
club with an n95 mask on it
but it's got some
look dude and the only reason i'm
wearing the mask is to keep me from
doing cocaine that's the only reason
all right looking like hannibal lecter
in the club club cocaine
you cannot trust the strip club cocaine
man i i
yeah they both have their uh advantages
i think the strip club
man it gets lit dude it's so funny is
the right one it's the right environment
no it's not somebody you and your homies
are there well but this plaxico burris
is there and he shoots you in the arm
i don't know if he's got a gun on him or
not but if he does he does
it's wrist he wants tipped a girl
the person shooting is himself but still
it's
so close it's close proximity i think uh
i'm gonna stay on the ranch this week
man i might go to the strip club next
week but i'm gonna stay on the ranch
oh i do love strip clubs but the ranch
is probably funner especially like cow
tipping you and your boys you're running
the field
oh that sounds gay dude i'm talking
about talking to some chick
no you're not rants no you're not no
you're not yes i am
ranch girls hey hey girl what you doing
out here on the ranch girl
like the girls on hey dude yeah like the
girls on hey dude bro malory
okay are you are you a big strip club
guy
um you know i do like to uh indulge in a
little boobies
and whatnot but uh i feel like it'd be a
sin if i didn't say a ranch with the
boys but
yeah i feel you well urban strip club
seems nice i'll probably go with the
strip club
i just think it's risque i'm not going
on uh derek chovin conviction night
though that's for sure no so i think if
you don't yeah maybe a couple weeks
after that i'll go
well i would go but i'm probably going
to give some lap dances out just to show
them my respect
[Laughter]
and there's the title of the episode
well look jim
thanks for being a part of our universe
man and we appreciate it bro
yeah i appreciate y'all man thanks for
everything y'all care brothers from the
best out i really appreciate it
all right guys thanks man later
huh that's a good question what would
you do me how walk or whatever that
kid's name is what the [ __ ] is that
boy's name
hey christian you down you you thinking
about the ranch you're trying to go to
that urban nightclub and shake
shake some asses uh i'm gonna be
completely honest
yeah please do guys we don't have a ton
of time okay i probably have to say
i'd have to say the ranch you've never
been in a strip club nah
hold on why are you going to be
completely honest about it
are you going to [ __ ] what are you
going to do
guys i'm going to be completely honest
with you man here
he's embarrassed yeah i mean every time
i say it people have the reaction like
you look oh you've never been to a strip
club
that was still something that was theo
that's still judging you i went to 11's
in miami during this whole pandemic dude
and it was it's dang it's great in there
but it's also dangerous there's a lot of
middle easterners
a lot of uh hookers rented hookers type
of thing
it's just it's getting a little dicey in
there a lot of size you know that little
thing that you see one of the
ninja turtles have the third or fourth
one oh oh you talking about the one with
three blades yeah
yeah somebody had that in there is it
hot though huh it wasn't a woman it was
a man there oh no i don't want that's
the thing i'm afraid of i'm not afraid
of the women's
i'm afraid of the man's at the place
you're paying too much time i'm not
trying to get shot
because i'm not trying to die well dude
enjoy the tits and ass and forget about
the man
it's very hard for one night forget
about the men
i'm not thinking about them man i don't
like men's anymore
so what do you say uh him him
child jesus how to figure it out
dude here's the plan with christian
we're gonna get you on a big stack of
steroids
you haven't gotten them anything what'd
you say we're gonna get you on a stack
of steroids so you get really juicy and
then we're going to get you in a strip
club
all right like i said i'm down maybe
clear it with your brother gianni
no no no i don't want it clear with
johnny what i would like is
you to actually follow through and do it
brenden you promised the freaking kid
hgh look at him no i didn't i don't want
him taking
didn't brendon say that he said i want
him on some real
arnold schwarzenegger gold's gym
steroids oh i'll get him on we're
talking
winnie we're talking about the [ __ ] you
used to do on the side of the road with
your boy
that pancake come here on that winstrol
the hits literally keep on coming from
one boxing event to the next
they grow in excitement and anticipation
and that's something about excitement
and anticipation they're really buddies
and they they travel together a lot
and this weekend is no different two of
the sports most
respected fighters stepping into the
ring
that's right there's no better place to
get in on all of that action
than with draftking sportsbook america's
top
rated app for this weekend's fight
draftkings is
offering all new users a shot
at turning one dollar in a 55
that's right to celebrate this weekend's
huge event draftking sportsbook
is offering new users the opportunity
to get 55 to one odds on either main
event fighter to win
this weekend's fight download the
top-rated draftking sportsbook app
now use code kats when you sign up
for a limited time all new users can bet
one dollar to win
55 on this weekend's main event
that's right draftkingsportsbook is
going all out for new users by offering
them the chance to win
55 when they placing a bet of one dollar
this weekend's big fight
must be 21 or older new jersey
indianapolis and pa only
new customers only restrictions apply
see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call 1800 gambler or in indiana 1-809
with it look with hellofresh you get it
you get the box it has the different
items it has the deal in there
you want the cabbage you want the
lettuce wraps baby
you want that donkey crunch meat you get
it all baby they got it all
it's quality effective meats cheeses
sausage vegetables you know it does it
all because it wants to do it all
and that's why hellofresh
cuts out stressful meal planning and
grocery store trips yep
you can enjoy cooking and get dinner on
the table in about 30 minutes or less
hellofresh has a wide variety of easy
delicious options for all three meals a
day plus every snack and special treat
in between
yep get better value hellofresh is 28
cheaper than shopping at your local
grocery store and 72 percent cheaper
than a restaurant meal without
sacrificing the quality
simply go to hellofresh.com slash 12
king and use code 12 king for 12
free meals including free shipping what
are you waiting for
that's right go to hellofresh.com
slash the number one the number two king
and use code 12 king for 12 free meals
including free shipping hello fresh
america's number one
meal kit what's up girl how you doing
me yeah how you doing damn what's up boo
sorry sorry i'm at work but i'm good
you look like you're about to get fired
i own it it's fine
you look like you're about to fire
yourself i should
what would you do for work um i own a
barbecue restaurant
in purvis mississippi oh
yeah petunias and you you own that place
i do me and my mom are co-owners and i
stay here and i run it every day
and it's pretty awesome now how are the
baby back ribs i always judge a barbecue
place off their ribs not their brisket
they're good they are very good now what
kind of what kind of sauce is we talking
here mama we talked you got spicy at
that sweet barbecue
so i'm working on it right now we just
opened a month ago
and i have a regular sauce just homemade
sweet and tangy and then i have
um kind of a spicy sauce in the works
but i'm not putting it out till it's
perfect so hopefully soon i can get that
out
all right amen now what about that some
people go to that vinegar type of sauce
route do you guys do anything like that
that clear sauce water look
it's almost a yellow we do more of like
a texas
style not so much like a north carolina
or anything with like more vinegary
mustardy yeah i don't like the vinegar i
love that petunia's barbecue and it also
looks like you have some type of a
dessert item or a fries or something
yeah i have uh their funnel cake fries
so they're kind of they taste more to me
like a fit like a skinny beignet but
they're like a funnel cake
but in the shape of a fry with uh
powdered sugar on my mouth so you got it
i'm going to give you a name for them
right now you got them thin
yays going on
i love it and i like it i think it would
help
but here's what i'm gonna say is this
dude uh i'll come over there and get a
cut a pig off of you
oh yeah oh yeah you know what i'm
talking about boo yeah i'll take a slab
myself
um and who's single that works over
there overall
um nobody i don't think
that's all right i like it i like
professional women
hey i like to hire women we work hard
amen i'm tired of these lazy ass
men out here me too man stealing
everything taking all your money to the
strip clubs
yeah exactly facts honey so is this a
barbecue joint ran by all women
um so me and my mom are owners of it and
then i have a lady running the kitchen
oh
she's actually my step sister her name's
shay um she
kicks ass and i will make sure she's
happy and stays for forever and then my
girl taylor
she is helps me run it and helps me keep
my brain straight because
the three brain cells i have left don't
really do too much sometimes when
there's 50 people lined up
yeah that barbecue do it that barbecue
will do it yeah yeah
we our first day we sold out in 35
minutes
oh dude damn girl yeah we had no idea
people were going to be so excited for
it and it's just a little
it's just a little shack kind of smoke
shack
a little smoke shack huh y'all only got
any of that little ring oh damn look at
that yeah
yeah i'm trying right next to my crack
that place will blow up i love it
now y'all got any of that ribbit ribbit
out there y'all selling any frog or any
of that rabbit
no i got brisket pulled pork smoked
wings and
ribs on the weekends okay praise god
all right and what can we do for you
today now uh
i wish we were closer i'd come eat no
yeah i'd go there right after this
hey we're not far from new orleans if
you take a quick trip how far would
drive is nashville to new orleans
i'm not going to get in this
conversation this is a boring
conversation but i'll tell both of you
guys and no offense to you no
you kind of started it yeah but no and
also no offense i'm curious how long
that is though
it's an eight hour it's about an eight
hour oh my god just fly seven and a half
hours
oh yeah yeah he's gonna stop by and eat
all your [ __ ] if it's free
i'll say that right now that's not me
i'll pay for your food
hey pay for pay for a brisket plate and
i'll give you a shirt how about this oh
now you got a reason to go now i will in
seal's defense he did give felons a few
hundred dollars
how about this we'll buy a couple shirts
and wear them on an episode can we do
that
absolutely i'll ship them to you gang
there we go well look what do you got a
king in her stinging or what today for
us are you just
is this a drunk dial what is this no
i sent an instagram message about king
or sting with
redheads we get a bad rap sometime
just a thought look you can bad wrap me
up in that little freaking water in that
water spout you know what i'm saying
yeah
yeah take it easy buddy uh yeah i'm
sorry
sorry i need help so yeah i haven't been
doing well and i know you guys are all
married
don't worry i'll tell his sponsor about
this conversation yeah
jesus christ don't feel too bad he
called this fat
guy fat kid the other day so we're doing
it
yeah he's oh he's cool with it uh can
you see it not doing well well
we we we got a local redhead who's
causing some issues his name is santino
so that's that's kind of the only sample
size we have do you know any other
redheads
i'll tell you this i knew a redhead when
i first was barely alive even probably
nine
and she was awesome and i don't see a
lot of redheaded men i don't think it's
four men
honestly we uh yeah we have a buddy in
our
circle kind of who's kind of a creep and
he has it but
yeah you don't see a lot of people
afflicted with it and they discontinued
it even at the sperm bank
but i like it on a woman i like it on a
woman and i think
i think it's unique that little touch of
strawberry i dig it
fire on the head fire in the heart
that's what they say
that's fair you know is there a lot of
redheads where you're at
no not really um mm-hmm i think there's
one other one that i see in town
oh cut that [ __ ] y'all should [ __ ]
have
there could only be one then have it out
yeah it's only going to be one
let's go
you gotta serve up a little bit of that
redhead one day
turn one of those baby back ribs in the
shank and take her ass out be the only
one
yeah hey if it's a customer they're more
than welcome
amen there we go well look when we get
close to petunias in purvis mississippi
we'll get over there
and uh thanks for calling in yeah i like
redheads i hope you guys stay alive
me too thank you i know the two percent
we're staying strong
but fight strong beat up somebody you
know take out another color
hey oh well
i'm just saying you know a lot of these
platinum blondes if they ain't [ __ ]
yeah a lot of these karen's thoughting
out they're great
and it's real everybody asks if it's
real it is real
oh yeah i've seen it that's why i mean
who's dying their hair
people some people say it's fool's gold
or whatever coming out of your head
that's a lie
that looks real from here girl oh you
vaping on the job too all right
what favors what flavor is that vape
blue ice
it's the it's a i don't know strawberry
lemonade
very simple oh okay just a little
nicotine
to keep the day going i feel okay yeah
yeah yeah i feel you
all right take care of yourself lady all
right thanks john
yeah thank you so much give me the
address all right all right thank you
bye thanks joe you came in hot huh i did
yeah
you think so a little bit look i've been
i've never been to purpose mississippi
but i've been
to purvis mississippi man ooh another
redhead
hi what's up girl
you guys in britain where are you guys
um i'm at san antonio texas oh
another san antonio in the house a lot
of texas today what's going on girl
what's cracking over there huh y'all
over there at the alamo huh
diy boarder house let's do it i guess
that's what we're known for right
um yeah no i'm just kind of chilling on
my lunch break
at work oh no what um
and what um what else brendan
uh what what are you taking a break from
what do you do for work
i do web design oh like a spider
so all that coding coding lingo
oh yeah it's like a spy check out the
big brain on brad
yeah what do you got for us girl i have
yeah i got a debate club for y'all um
please i'm polyamorous
uh been polly for a little while now and
i'm just kind of loving it
uh getting to openly date whoever i want
be in relationships maybe not be in
relationships you know just
living how i want to live um but the
debate club would be polyamory slash
non-monogamy versus monogamy so
polyamorous that means you're into guys
girls whatever um it's more so just that
you're not monogamous in your
relationships
oh thank you for clarifying that thank
you
yeah um
i think it's uh i think it's i mean
it sounds lonely it sounds
oh quite the opposite brandon oh really
thank you
yeah yeah quite the opposite brendan i
mean you get to to be with as many
people as
as you want to be with that's kind of
yeah bro
there it's about love man it's about
like the 1970s and about
being in love you freaked
is it a popular trend i feel like it is
especially with the younger crowd
um yeah i'd say it's definitely more
popular with younger
people than older people now what's the
downside to being polyamorous
you have to give us one good question
actually yeah that is a good question
the only thing i can think of is that a
lot of people don't really fully
understand it
right so like sometimes they'll think
like oh like i'm
polyamorous until i find someone that i
want to be monogamous with but that's
like not
oh so you're saying once you go polly
you gotta stay polly
well i mean there's a there's a saying
like my poly is not your poly so like
polly's pretty much different for
every single person that does it like
there's not really one single definition
if you want to so polyamorous when it
comes to different colored macaroons i
know that
yeah i like them all daddy yeah i've
seen this guy
yeah i make macaroons really so what so
for for you so like right now how many
people are you
are you seeing um
so i have one person that i'd consider
like a partner but then i'm dating also
a couple and then i'm i have another
male that's like a more like friends
with benefits situation
and i have a female who's like rent a
benefit situation okay
it sounds like a lot of work though
paulie sounds like work
love is infinite but time is finite baby
yeah
yeah you got to get your little chubby
[ __ ] out there brendan
today so what i want to tell you is what
i'm proud of you
and yeah you can do whatever you want
you know what i'm saying somebody's got
to keep things hot around town
and then some of us are polly in the
closet
no polly want a cracker come on out dawg
pollywood community man the only thing i
like is women and that's it if i see
hey nobody believe in that dude
would you say you can be polly and only
like women
thank you very much and that's me you
got to share that ass with the world
oh yeah there you go i mean there's your
new [ __ ] counselor dog
i like it look i'm just happy to be
alive and i'm glad you're alive and i'm
glad that you're able to date other
people
i think if you can handle it i think at
some point it just seems like
i don't want to get cornered into a
space where like you're like you go to
get drinks from the bar or something you
and you you turn around and you got like
your boyfriend's over there and then
your husband's over there and then
you're
you know your son who you're dating also
is over there
and you don't know where to what table
to take the drinks back to you right now
you got to buy 19 drinks you're going
broke buying a round
i don't want to need a van just to date
you know like that that's the only thing
that sounds a little yeah i don't waste
money on
uber plus just to get it done you know
yeah i don't want to uh yeah i think uh
i think
that's the only thing would be the um
the too much
having too much going on but if you can
handle it more power to you i can i'm
not built for that life
yeah no if you got that yeah i think if
you can get out there and you got that
shop vac [ __ ] get it out there and do
work you feel me and no
offense but but a little effective
sorry but a little hopefully you gotta
beat yourself also be careful nowadays
though
that's my nickname for brendan also shot
back [ __ ] so
it is what it is i've actually never
heard that term but
it's a little offense for sure sorry
stay with the offense
i didn't check the name with him first
so i should have um
but look i think yeah you gotta love i
think put as much love as you can out
there
but don't just miss don't miss out on an
opportunity to strap something good down
when you got something good
yeah strap it on yeah good good luck
though yeah
more power to you girl we support it all
right thanks
man yeah good luck yeah keep ganging it
and buzzing it
yeah gang gang buzz balls buzz buzz girl
wow huh who could i mean it's just a lot
of work
man it's redhead fever out here today
dude there's so many redheads
redhead summer we got a lot of redhead
fans
dude i got some white boy summer merch
oh really yeah from chet hanks yeah
sick i think it's at home i didn't look
but i think it is did you purchase it or
did you like reach out
purchased it that's awesome
black queen summer yeah those were sold
out i think i didn't get any
i'm not sure which one it was could you
guys do the polyamorous thing
chin hell no nick no i'd be too jealous
yeah same here i'd be too jealous chuck
steak could do it or what sorry whatever
meat hulk
you can't do it either i i do it but i
want to let my girl do it
oh dude so what you're talking about
you're talking about sex slave
you're talking about cheating on your
girl yeah well i could cheat on as long
as she doesn't
yeah that's the hard part man i think i
i think it'd be stressful
and that has to be lonely at some point
how long are you gonna do this [ __ ]
for well how long you do this for at
least until i'm 41
but what i'm saying is i've been
polyamorous for a long time i think if
it's just dating people
that's what yeah it sounds like she just
dates people
yeah she has a bunch and she's open to
guys and girls did she say oh yeah she
said guys and girls so i'm just open to
girls
and other girls but here's a guy right
here
here's a freaking rat king what's up
playboy
you want to tickle that nickel
tyler from washington state here you got
a quick king understand it
got that rat king clearly now sting
those crowds the vermin with the sermon
king interesting yard games like
cornhole
you're going to king it you're going to
sting it it's about 70 degrees in
washington right now which i know from
california ain't [ __ ]
but for us this is warm king intersting
yard games like cornhole
behind no look steph curry style dog
no washington you i think they got rid
of cornhole i don't think they can even
play cornhole anymore
would that man ask oh cornhole for men
yard games in general first of all yard
games and i'll be honest with you as a
gateway to homosexuality dog
it can be yeah okay let's play right
here you get a
few bears deep you start winning your
boys start hugging yeah oh i can't
believe you made that shot
next time your shirts are off yeah dude
who's
skins
and there's your episode title name
we're all scared bro that is your
you start doing front side piggy backs
that's when it gets scary when
somebody's like piggyback but on the
front
yeah or when you're doing wheel or or
when you're doing wheelbarrow
i'm in the room but they haven't been
patching what's up dog
wheelbarrows when the uh that's that
rickshaw
that guy was with his dad show us your
dad again yeah get your dad back
oh you want to see my dad again he's
doing pull-ups in the doorway
what's up
[Laughter]
and he's laughing too hard yeah yeah bro
i mean i can't believe marty back on i
was on the patreon one just the other
day
what's going on oh yeah welcome back
yeah it was the the floss yeah i
remember dude yeah you look like i
thought you look like that killer guy
the um the
guy that killed those people in his
apartment remember that movie
the american psycho american psycho oh
cool yeah he's good looking dude he's
all
hell yeah i thought yeah that's
christian bale
what's going on
dude what yeah like christian bale from
christian build a hay bale
yeah hey how do you how do you feel
about wheel bearing with the boys
yeah a wheelbarrow with the boys is that
like a like a double meaning or
something or what
nah you just take your boy by the ankles
and then you [ __ ] raise them up
and he walks on his hands remember that
game that they used to have that workout
in
middle school football we do that yeah
it was great right that was a fun time
did you guys ever do field day at school
did you ever have something called
field day dog oh blue ribbons
all day long all day remember that oh
nothing better and one of the games
would just throw something as far as you
can i remember that game
we had this black girl in our school she
was like 35 years old right she was in
her class
she threw a stapler like 120 yards
wow and she won i went to predominantly
black
school so when we do the sprint it was
tough man
it was tough but when you do that right
i did not
it was easy yeah i got some blue ribbons
i got i got a closet full of blue
ribbons my nephew actually just did a
field day
he got a bunch of blue ribbons and he's
white too so hey man brother that's what
i'm talking about matthew bowling let's
go
man they still do fear that's texas man
matthew bowling's in texas i think does
he go to
ut or no where do you go who the [ __ ]
matthew baldwin i'm i'm honestly not
sure
matthew i have no idea matthew bowling
is the
is that the guy that's the white kid
that's beating everybody oh the wrestler
oh yeah the runner yeah i know you're
talking about georgia
bulldog oh he went to his job oh yeah
he's and he's on the olympic team right
yeah he's doing the lord's work yeah
he's going
crazy fast yeah yeah yeah matthew
bowling man
legend bro legend what's going on today
brother what you got king of her sting
in it
yeah yeah i got a i got a debate club i
was working and i saw that uh on patreon
it pop up for us to ask a question or
whatever so i did it and they just sent
me a link
so uh yeah so i got a debate club i'm
just thinking of
and brenda you have the kids you
probably i don't know probably have an
opinion on this more than us but
what about that heehaw seesaw
versus that swing set that swinging baby
which one yeah i love a nice swing set
the problem with that see-saw
it's all about injuries these days so as
a parent you always gotta
you always kind of gotta you know you're
stressed out depending on the injury
those seesaws you don't listen there
ain't many see-saws in la man
i i think they got rid of them yeah
there's a lot of brilliant sea salt yeah
there's virtual ones here
where you're you and your kid the kids
stand like 10 feet apart and imagine
that they're on a see-saw
it's a bomber now swings are still
pretty lit though there's swings
everywhere
yeah and there's like um yes
there's like a closet on a lot of the
playgrounds there's a closet on it and
the kid can practice coming out of the
closet out here in los angeles
yeah they actually encourage i feel this
seesaw is like a bully like people can
use it to bully have you ever seen that
in cartoons yeah
see-saw up and down on somebody yeah on
their head they would do that a lot yeah
a lot of times
they would um yeah kid was a little too
aggressive somebody really pounced it up
get you up there and threaten you [ __ ]
yeah make you throw your lunch money
down they used to do that sometimes to
get off of there
remember the one not the merry-go-round
but it's like that was like the
the thing and someone would run and spin
it around mirrors metal
oh yeah [ __ ] yeah that shit's all
dangerous people always die
out there but you gotta thin the herds
some people can't handle the heat now i
was on a swing set the other day i took
a date to a uh
like a park and then we got on the
swings man
wow what are you 14 do you did you start
sweating when you held her hand
was it midnight was it park hours right
it was park houses daytime hours
did that's a cute idea i like it we had
a thank you nick
it was a nice idea nick slept in a park
last night
i thought he's okay with this
nick they saw how big are those swings
you have to like maybe put them together
lay down them like a hammock
i'm sick of this anti-homeless
architecture they're putting everywhere
it's hard to get a good night's rest
yeah so yeah we had a nice time man
the scary part was when you get so fast
on that swing you get that feeling in
your stomach when you go back
like a roller coaster like and then if
you start going too high starts
yeah it gets scary oh yeah you're trying
to go all the way around
yeah when you're a kid you're trying to
go all it never happened never happened
for me
i liked it i
i was that kid that kid was always in
the high ankle sprain
yeah who had a few ankles no i used to
do that too yeah i was too heavy to be
doing that but you would get so high
straight up at the skies thought you was
going to be in like a space or something
that was fun you break your arm you go
from a swing to a swing oh yeah
very popular man yeah i vote swing set
man i'm swing set now on your date did
you get behind your girl and pusher
um no i didn't i thought about it still
it's too high
slow down i thought about it and then if
you really want to get into it you push
her and you run
underneath so she really flies oh that's
crazy brenda oh yeah that's crazy you
got to be careful
make sure you clear it because they'll
come back on you yeah if you don't
run out far enough well well yeah i
didn't get into all that you guys are
freaking
pretty romantic i said okay well look
let's get out of this conversation
before brennan tells another story about
crow cop
okay so okay all right thanks zach
be good zach take care brother brother
wow seem like a nice guy and he said he
works where he does lawn care
i don't know what he was doing his dad
made a little cameo
yeah his dad definitely uh seemed like a
nice man huh
kitchen man dad's usually in the kitchen
the dad's chilling
dad's in the kitchen man what else you
got nick uh we got another guy coming in
i just had to restart zoom he got and
these are all felons
no these are just people oh my god i
thought these were felons again
yeah well know if they were you've been
giving out money that's true
hey felon yeah the good money the good
upstanding citizen he buys a couple
t-shirts
yeah right yeah that's true
god that's horrible i felt so bad about
all that felon money i gave out
oh you're a felon we'll give you six
hundred dollars
but you see how it's see how easy it is
for an administration to give away it's
just like
you just have to do it you're saying
what if we just said hey we're gonna
think about it for
seven months and then send you 1200.
yeah it might
show up in your bank account we'll see
we'll see
it's so crazy and i want to let you know
that i have
some tour dates as well uh they go on
sale
tomorrow morning friday may 7th
at 10 a.m central standard time and
those are
at theovon.com tour
thank you in advance for your support
those are in
st louis cincinnati charlotte
durham north carolina chattanooga
tennessee knoxville
wilmington delaware wilkes bar
pa minneapolis
charleston richmond
baltimore albany buffalo
and columbus ohio so uh theovon.com
tour to check those out this summer i'm
considering going to hot springs
arkansas
and i'm not even sure why but i am
considering that
and i want to let you know that if
you're considering going somewhere sunny
beruta
hawaii miami
then what you need to do is get a pair
of raycon wireless earbuds in your ears
to make all the difference sometimes you
want to put your own sound to match the
beautiful environment you're at
whether you're in istanbul or croatia or
sacramento
sometimes you want to match the beauty
of the world with your own sounds
raycon can help you you get crisp
powerful beats at half the price of
other premium auto brands
raycons look great and feel even better
god it feels good going in your ear they
come in a range of cool colors
with customizable gel tips included for
a comfortable
in-ear fit that's right listen up
raycon's offering 15
off all their products right now so
that's all their products not one
product that's many products
for our listeners and here's what you've
got to do to get it go to buy raycon
dot com slash k a t s that's b u y
r a y c o n dot com slash k-a-t-s
there you'll get 15 off your entire
raycon order
and it's such a good deal you'll want to
grab a pair and
and a spare that's 15 off
at buy raycon.com rake
cats you know recently i got a new car
i got a car it's not new actually i got
a used
truck so i didn't get a new car at all
but i got a used truck
and what i'm trying to tell you about is
damn edmonds dude damn edmonds
edmonds it's called not damn edmonds
edmonds has been taking the stress out
of the entire car
shopping process for over 50 years
at edmonds they know cars at edmonds you
can get reviews
appraisals see millions of listings
and run a price checker know that what
you're spending is what you should be
spending
or what you're going to offer is what
you should be going to offer
that's right edmunds gives you the
resources for every part of the process
whether you're buying or selling both
ways
every year edmonds editors drive more
than 500 000 miles
and conduct over a thousand hours of
testing on hundreds of new vehicles
whether you're just browsing or know
exactly what car you want edmunds is the
place to go get expert reviews
accurate pricing free appraisals
millions of listings
and more simply visit edmunds.com and
click the car reviews tab at the top of
the page to start researching
vehicle reviews and rankings that's
edmunds.com
for cars there's edmunds
oh yeah you're married we're not the
ladies today i'm not married
you'll be taking girls all right guys
i'm a little tired so forgive them
but i've got a king understand it for ya
peg leg crutches theo posted something
about those scooters
that are supposed to be a substitute for
crutches
but crutches tuck the scooter suck peg
leg crutches are where it's at
so take a look at my photo and tell me
can't get or sting it
gang gang buzz buzz buzz buzz young lady
what's a peg leg you're going to see she
got that slim limb baby
oh no flex what's his name the
protrusion guy the guy who murdered his
fine ass girlfriend oh yeah petrarius
yeah
that guy shot his lady in the tub huh
yeah he did thought it was a [ __ ]
thief dude who who thinks a thief is
coming in your house and then taking a
bath
oh god figure it out dude and then she
was like no it's me
and he's still shy but he said that she
went no
it's me yeah he's like well she has a
deep voice
she was bad she was hot too he was hot
man
yeah the old yeah zoom in on that limb
baby yeah
i wish we knew what she did let me see
that limb daddy
i feel like it'd be a nightmare dude
just zoom in on walk around like do that
do that walking around like a pirate
ship look at that limb baby damn that
thing's nice
yeah you're looking you liking that knee
dude i put that thing in my damn
in my mouth boy you suck that kneecap
huh
no no i'll put the whole [ __ ] leg in
my mind turns out there's a limit of the
amount of women we can have on here
theo's out of control today am i you a
pervert dog
oh my bad you need a massage i need to
miss you
that little tie kid again jump on your
back yeah
is his name is that a better move than
the scooter that you posted the scooter
thing is
unbelievably aggravating dude that
little thing
it looks like a little like they just
pushed it around on wheels like the
people at
uh disney world yeah you get your knee
on a thing and then you push it on the
wheels
yeah it's i feel like that thing looks
stupid too
though that thing's that pogo stick yeah
how about you yeah that's a [ __ ] pogo
stick how about you just
do the old school crotches man that
thing is uh uh
what is that that's that pirate huh
that's that winch bent
yeah i think what do you think meat
meter yeah me boy what is his name
meathawk what do you think man what
would you peter's a good name
was it a king a singer i'd king it okay
and when you date a woman like this
would you date a woman that's
handicapped like this
uh do i know her before she it happens
or am i with her when it happened no you
meet her and she has one leg
doug no you're with her and you couldn't
protect her
uh yeah because it didn't happen to me
so why not yeah oh wow
you made it better and if even if it
happened before
then it depends honestly
like if it's a bird like i don't know
like it honestly depends on the person
dude if she's hot enough i can get well
yeah
that's what i'm saying yeah you guys do
yeah you guys i know both of you guys
actually i just realized that what about
you
huh would you yeah i put this lady in a
damn castle
okay not like you [ __ ] maybe i'd
take her to lunch
your time i'd take him to a park with
one leg i don't think she'd do well at
the park yeah you know how relaxing
would be for her to be on the swings and
to be off of her leg
probably gonna have that see-saw but she
got that tom dempsey dude look up tom
dempsey real quick
she got that tom dempsey dog she's
swinging that down 63-yarder right there
baby you feel me
pull up your i'd like to know what
injuries she has pull up your boy
tom dempsey son she got that td
right there boom right that kicker let's
go
that is a thick [ __ ] dip see she's
running
on dude she's shooting three from deep
he even was missing part of his hand
look at his hand in that picture
he only got part of a hand and part of a
foot damn he passed away last year
he kicked a 63 yarder he kicked a 63
yard he had the nfl record for about 40
years
to my boy jason elam said hold my
[ __ ] hand and kick the [ __ ] out yeah
it's easy to say that when you have two
hands okay tom had one freaking hand
yeah
and he had a five iron for a foot bro
yeah i feel like yeah that's an
advantage he'll put that thing through
your mother's freaking bus stop damn
look at that club
that's what i'm talking about so look i
say king it man death what is it deaf
people
yeah yeah i said i like legs yeah i say
king and if that's your thing
that's what's comfortable [ __ ] do it
but also decorate that [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying like if it's cinco de
mayo put a little
throw some streamers yeah get a little
graffiti on that [ __ ] yeah dude there's
a little art on there man yeah also
if you think about it if you do date a
girl with a peg leg think about all the
fire parking you're going to have with
that ooh
do you front row like front row right
out front i mean come on do you feel
like drake
yeah yeah you have a line at the airport
yeah
and then you carry a girl in like a
freaking legend like uh
tony like not tony robbins i'm about to
have chappelle cut his [ __ ] leg off
yeah so we get front row everywhere do
it or malek
yeah one of them would do it bro you
don't even need both of them yeah you're
right
um or not both of them completely legged
no at least get a sling for one of them
someone needs to ditch a leg yeah
oh get an eye patch for malik oh that's
a good idea
i could see that he'll probably like
bedazzle and [ __ ] whatever
it's a new fad yeah yeah what we got
what's up brother can you see us
hey guys what's up dog what's up playboy
how are you guys chilling fans of the
show big very big fans
oh thanks man yeah thanks for checking
in with us dude what um
what's uh where are you at today uh i'm
currently living in dubai
in the middle east yeah and uh my dad is
indian and my mom's from the philippines
so i'm like a mixed race kid over here
oh that's cool man and now is that
frowned upon over there
no i know it's completely normal a lot
of mixed-race couples over here in the
middle east
a lot of expat communities so like
everyone's like mingling with each other
trying to see which has like the hottest
babies you know regular stuff
is it tough to tell with women out there
because they're all covered up they're
like this
oh man it'll surprise you everyone here
is like wearing tank tops
booty shorts everything oh but just
their faces
no no no they're like those are like the
local emirati women but
uh everyone else is like 90 of the uae
population is all expats so yeah like
british
asian you name it they're here but i but
i thought if you're a girl and you hung
out with your tits they cut your head
off but
brendan he's telling you that's not that
what happens you keep asking him and he
keeps telling you no i understand
brendan's point of view as well that
that was there in the past but now it's
like it's very liberal now yeah you can
do it
in the 90s i heard dubai's lit as [ __ ] i
heard it's vegas on steroids now do you
guys have this young man do you guys
have um
the cove there or no people aren't
worried about it
oh yeah we have a lot of cases but it's
actually subsided because
the government has done a lot to bring
in the vaccine i just got my second dose
yesterday
as well so how are you feeling man two
dose danny out here
i was out completely yesterday but today
so much better i managed to hit the gym
did all my regular stuff but we're still
working from home
now do you feel like um is there it
seems like
only rich people can be in dubai is it
like a real is it like
a real rich kind of place like is that
is there a middle class
that's a good question uh i'm in the
middle class actually but
uh there are a lot of rich folks over
here like seeing a lamborghini or
ferrari every day is just like whatever
you know some people stop to take
pictures and stuff but for the majority
of us it's like whatever that's just
another car in the city
yeah but i think if you're middle class
over there that means you're high class
in the states
because i bet the middle class over
there
yeah i think you could say that i think
you could say that but there's still
like a lot of
um like let's say asian expats who come
here and just like work in construction
yeah and all that so like they obviously
don't get a lot of like big salaries or
anything like that but you have
everything here from the low
minimum wage class to the upper elite
class over here that's cool man
have you seen the serpent on netflix oh
my god
uh no i can't say that no one has it's a
good show if you like it
no the guy is indian and um
oh and he has to see it he's an indian
in it the guy's indian and asian
and but he's a crime he does crime he
commits murder
crime guy yeah crime guy what do you got
i'm a clean guy guys
okay yeah what do you got for us brother
yeah man what do you have for us dude
tell us something good
uh so like since you're in a subject
i'll be like you know high middle class
my my job is actually
my my question is actually about jobs so
i've been in my job for around
eight years now it's a desk job and i
completely hate it and like there's a
point there's a part of me which
actually wants to quit my job right now
quit i like pursue my passion
quit uh and stuff [ __ ] quit dude what
is the passion
symbolism yeah good question so so i
have a i have a podcast with my
girlfriend
and um i also actually do stand-up
comedy here in dubai
oh wow so it's like it's like a it's
like a mixture of votes
but i that's the thing it's easy for
it's easier said than done obviously but
then like
it's not passion it's not though because
you're what you
i'm you're just at this job for uh
security right because of the money and
[ __ ] like that but
when you're 50 you're going to hate your
[ __ ] life dude
and what so you own a home and i already
hate my life yeah there you go you're
miserable
you [ __ ] hate your life you're
calling to us for advice so you hate
your [ __ ] life dude
quit right now man quit and see what
happens because
what kind of you do computer programming
or some [ __ ] what do you do
so i work in a logistics so it's like i
do basically sales customer service
yeah there you go that's that's never
going to get better battleship you play
replay battleship hell yeah
b24 hey here's the thing dude that that
job's never going to go anywhere too you
can only fight you can always find a job
doing logistics
but for you to take advantage of doing
stand-up and dubai
or podcasting blowing that thing up
doing what you want man
logistics ain't going anywhere that's me
around for [ __ ] ever dude
quit right now well
does your girl have a job yeah she has a
job she's working as well
[ __ ] quit and is she like does she
would she be upset if just she were
working you think or what do you think
she would think
i i i'm not too sure about that actually
but
uh i'm planning to propose to her very
soon so i think that might also be okay
that's also in my mind you know like
during all that kind of stuff so i don't
know if it's like premature if i
actually do it okay
quit or should i like maybe a couple of
months not quit right now
you can't quit and then propose yeah you
can that's in that's
that's that's quite that's that's that's
insane yeah
i think i just think you got to be a
risk taker what is the podcast about
uh so my girlfriend is half lebanese
half filipino so
our podcast is called half a nice day so
we just talk about anything and
everything like life as we know it our
experiences growing up like as a as a
mixed-race kid
what about flips is that a racial
meaning
if somebody says flips for filipinos is
that a racial slur or not
no no no it's not it's okay good i don't
i don't see it as it as it is yeah
do you guys do you guys have like
protests and [ __ ] out there like blm
protests and stuff or is it kind of
chill out there oh no
zero zero
yeah it's a bunch of straight up sand
christians dude but their government
ain't gonna put up with it though
you try that [ __ ] out there you go
missing son yeah i think
is the government pretty this pretty
legit out there is it pretty stout
uh they're quite strict they're quite
strict any any naysayers about the
government you can like
i can go missing literally wow yeah now
that's a podcast i could go missing
and you just each week you test how much
you can say
each week you test how much you can say
on two you go missing yeah
but i like half a nice day look i think
you got your girl dialed into the work
so at least if you do quit she's like
she's a part of it so she'll feel like
maybe you guys are doing this thing
together
um how old are you um
i just turned 30. oh yeah oh dude i'm a
pisces brother as well
oh hell yeah dog welcome uh yeah dude i
mean you're 30 man so what are you going
to wait to your 40
you start doing stand up when you're 40.
he could be 30 40 31
32 he could be any number 30 is good
time to get going doug
yeah i just don't know i'll be on your
destination being like oh my gosh
because of the pandemic so there's no
massive gathering so i haven't done
comedy in like around three four months
now that's [ __ ]
for me is the podcast yeah that should
open up yeah i would wait until things
are a little bit stronger before you cut
bait with the job man
you got to be working you got to bring
in some type of income nick what do you
think
yeah uh and i i think go a little bit
more niche with your podcast
uh since people don't know who you are
it's hard to just like tune in and hear
about just general life
like so talk about something grow from
there and then expand
yeah mm-hmm does he have anything we
have around 200 subscribers but it's
like growing every day at least we see
like one or two subscribers every day
for now
nice man what language is it in it's in
english it's 100 english
english nick well man
uh dang i wish we had some advice for
you ah man i would quit and
pursue the dream that's what i would do
i'm a risk taker though i also have cte
though
i also have ct so if you guys rent money
quit but if not
now you'll figure i get you'll figure it
out you're a smart kid man but you're
gonna be [ __ ] miserable working this
shitty desk job to your 40. i like what
you're doing
i like going to the office well he
[ __ ] hates it he hates him they have
people's birthdays
everything everybody's come in the
kitchen no you're working for the man
he's making all the profit they give you
the [ __ ]
salary then they then exactly and
exactly
[ __ ] you know hawaiian shirt friday
to keep morale up
that's true yeah
we have it yeah brendan's
i'll wear hawaiian shirt where the [ __ ]
i want look at the way i'm dressed dude
that's true good luck though my man
you're already on the right path i got a
feeling thank you so much yeah you're
gonna figure it out
yeah brendan looks like a bat boy on
gianni versace softball team
um look man i think you're doing look it
sounds like you got a good head on your
shoulders i would wait to quit your job
until after you get married that's the
new
white boy summer you know that's when
it's a white boy summer forever
dude get that rock on your girl and get
that blood diamond dog you close to the
freaking
you know to those artery miners over
there get that freaking big bdz on your
lady i i would wait till things open up
so you can start doing a bunch of open
mics and [ __ ]
at least wait till it opens up but as
soon as that [ __ ] opens up i'd quit
and get that illegal rock dog you're so
close to africa over there you could get
that freaking
i mean that thing should test positive
that thing should test be
positive dog that diamond yep
there he is all right praise god brother
be good advice from you guys then
yeah good luck man hopefully that helped
yeah i bet it didn't but we love you
brother
praise god gang baby if it doesn't work
out don't blame me have a good life man
be good oh this is this guy is god has
killed somebody this guy's stealing
packages what's going on y'all chillin
man you do you
you do deliveries for amazon uh
that's right sir i'm not here you know
i'm the blue santa claus out here every
day
hell yeah man i love the packages your
mom does that yeah
my mom does that in baton rouge if you
see the rat queen out there
you know who it is what's going on sarah
where are you
were you at tucson uh right now i'm out
here in uh uh
phoenix az oh not my station's on uh
phoenix i'm right now i'm in peoria just
uh slinging these packages
oh yeah out by glendale baby i know
where you at
oh yeah yeah i almost got i [ __ ] my
car broke down out there one time and
i almost got hit by a semi-trailer when
i was urinating and
dark you know what's real scary at night
is if your car doesn't work
they can't see you to be out by the side
of the interstate
bro it's harrowing where a lot of people
die oh yeah because they can't see you
oh but anyway man uh we're glad you're
alive today dude
what you got man you got a king of her
stinging what's cracking
yeah i got a relationship advice so um
i got a girlfriend right and uh she
doesn't really deal with touch all that
well so like if i hug her
that she she'll deal with it but she's
not really all about that
so how would y'all deal with that oh a
lot of our friends have dealt with that
yeah uh deal with that horned toe doug
that's what's happening oh tell them
tell us brenda yeah
horned toads don't like get touched go
in on him drop it on him you just got to
keep giving her that love until she
finally just breaks those walls down and
realize you're
you you a touchy man you know just keep
[ __ ] touching or touching her every
day man
now here's an idea too because that
sounds like you're going to get an
assault charge yeah it does as i was
coming out of my mouth i thought
it's 20 21 bruh yeah you can't touch a
woman these days
here's what you do you get a shirt you
do paint remember them paint hand prints
that turkey hand that a kid would make
at school make that turkey hand right
make a shirt like that with a bunch of
turkey hands on it
give it to your lady say look i'm trying
to make some moves
but i figure we start right here you
know
i mean i'll see i'll give it a go see if
she deals with that uh
second grade art project see if she'll
like that yeah sounds like a terrible
idea
uh how long have you been how long have
you been dating her
uh it's been uh about like i wanna say
uh about a year and a half about oh yeah
bro hit her with that arts and shafts
baby i'm telling you dude that thing
will lead to some sex though yeah more
shaft than art though yeah let me start
with the art dude yeah man
yeah not with brendan's freaking reach
around on yourself tactics over here
dude i'm sorry i went to the brian cowan
school for women
vernon your [ __ ] best friend bro is
he under that bus over there
bro here's what i'm saying is brendan
is also the kind of guy who will draw
freaking tits on himself and [ __ ]
and touch himself so yeah well man you
got to take care of it i think you got
to do something nice maybe get one of
those get a fake a prosthetic arm and
set it on your girl's back
or or you could get one of those hot ass
uh dummies they have you know those like
builder girls
and then just show her how much you like
to touch yeah
like you won't do it so i'm gonna do it
on this one leave my girlfriend for long
if i keep doing that
well look yeah hey listen man you gotta
crack a few eggs and make an omelette
especially want to touch that omelette
yeah you're right
yeah bro now maybe it might be a
childhood trauma where she doesn't like
to be touched have you ever talked about
that
it's 100 that yeah yep see now we're on
to something maybe get her a turtleneck
or something because that kind of it's
like a little bit of pressure but it's
not heavy pressure
yeah it's like a shield yeah dude maybe
get a betterhelp.com promo code cat
yeah yeah you could also i guess i'm
catching
i'll tell you this man a friend of mine
told me this recently this man
he said he had sexual education uh
he had erectile dysfunction and he was
with his girl for like a year and a half
and finally it went away he said
and that's it yeah it went away
damn i appreciate that story yeah
hopefully that helps out what i'm saying
is that it
it could change if you just give it time
man but how much time is he going to
give her she doesn't want to be touched
man my
my boy here is touchy feet a dog it
sounds like also
i want to throw this out there you could
have kidnapped this woman bro
yeah yeah what if you're a freaking sex
offender
yeah that's a good question across the
uh denny's parking lot and kind of just
picked her up and took her but yeah
she's always trying to escape and [ __ ]
from the basement man it's getting
really annoying yeah
dude yeah so look
if anything tell her if she needs to
escape just promo codecats escape.com
promo
cats yeah she keeps forgetting her my
name ain't like let me out so
yeah that's a tough [ __ ] well look man
good luck with her dude i think finding
some cute way to show her that you want
to apply a little bit of pressure you
know
maybe put a rock on her back or
something like that just something light
you know maybe just keep giving her
massages every day man
start with a nice massage on the feet
yeah start with that neck work
then work it up dog praise god man stay
safe out there bro
yeah good luck i will man man i love
y'all uh y'all really do bite my day
yeah keep touching me dog oh thanks
sergio keep touching me baby be good
your girl says don't touch me i said
keep touching me yeah get her don't
touch me shirt
that's not actually a bad idea at all
good idea i can't believe you took us
that long to get to a good idea
that was a tough one to figure out i
didn't know if he kidnapped the girl or
what
yeah very alarming and i still don't
even know he might even work for amazon
dude we have no idea what's her doing
you never know here's gianni right here
what's up gianni
alex alex how you going man you in uh
you in britain no oh hell no
no orlando orlando florida close though
oh
close up the books your mom gave you
what do you got for us doug
oh god debate club real quick for y'all
yeah let us see it baby
hit us with that hammer dude any
questions gonna be tough for brendan
throw it out
uh watching a pay-per-view fight with
friends or by yourself
this is good huh this is good hashtag
ufc 261 that brendan used about a couple
of weeks ago
i saw you on there at night huh no i
don't [ __ ] lose thumbs
pull up can we get to the tweet that he
did
was it the hauling fight where i said
holland's most exciting fighter
i usually don't tweet during the fights
oh
never never
say something just say something
something there you go
do you tweet during the fight i have a
twitter i don't think i've ever posted
anything
some of you guys do
oh [ __ ] chin hit his head
damn what do you guys do that's actually
going to leave a mark too that hit hard
it's all good it's all good
let's stick with alex man i'm sorry i'm
taking this thing off course dude
no it was a while back i shouldn't have
brought it up
it was just a tweet it was just a no no
audio or pictures or not
i mean i'd say kevin holland's uh one of
the most entertaining fighters but it
wasn't like hashtag nothing i'm not
trying to make that ufc
yeah let's see that hashtag boys boys
261
no yeah yeah i just searched brendan
schaub and ufc
hashtag ufc 261 and i didn't nothing
came up there it is right there oh
right there oh
that is a kevin holland one that's kevin
holland well well well
hashtag vegas 22.
that was after the fight though oh was
it brendon was it
9 25 p.m he was right about fighting
yeah
he's right about the most entertaining
and in the blue corner
brynden hash brown
sub hash brown with that hash tag
baby he's the most entertaining fighter
he loses one more he ain't gonna be too
entertaining man
oh we'll see man you guys should both
try to get on this weekend
ufc 261. we'll have to hashtag it man
they won't let me on
yeah they will no no really you've just
made too many i talk too much [ __ ] yeah
well you and steve oh no who's more
thirsty dude yeah
you're right there steve does way too
you're right there
no it's stevo and then who else does too
many nick uh i like this guy
jedi goodman he he's got uh he
usually has like information that goes
on there look at his
wow dude but he's a journalist yeah but
he gets on there
all the time he's a journal i mean he's
he's he has a media pass
yeah yeah he's no they don't count he
should get on there
yeah it's massive usman huh here come
the hot step uh
so he's talking about uh i prefer
pay-per-views with uh by myself man
yeah let's get into that my issue is i
get too many stupid questions all the
time from friends and family oh really
the worst i like it's like listen to the
[ __ ] podcast i did on monday when i
broke the fight down yeah you're like
doing a podcast or in the middle of the
goddamn fight
it's exhausting look i want to see jake
paul versus mike perry is what i want to
see
that's what i said you obviously listen
to the podcast and i appreciate it thank
you yeah
i do listen i listened to that episode
and i thought it was good man thanks man
and uh i think that that's the guy to go
fight me too i think at least if you're
gonna fight
you just gotta fight somebody who's
willing to [ __ ] he's only who can
take some licks he's young though man he
has three fights
yeah that's the way fighting goes you
shouldn't be fighting killers your first
three fights
agreed so mike perry i feel like it
would be
i feel like it would be much more f
mike perry will throw some hands though
then mike perry can take a shot too
right
that's what i'm saying i don't think
you're gonna knock mike perry out
he could but it'd be tough but he should
go dylan danis then mike perry
i think you'll find them both at the
same time you could you know what i'm
saying let let freedom ring dawg
yeah i mean trilla's probably up for it
oh trillers definitely i'm surprised
somebody to get
shot during that time like oh they will
they look nice
ratchet dude i'm like is this on a
jungle gym get some [ __ ] lighting in
there that was a nightmare unbelievable
yeah it reminded me of like the time
that i got stuck at this nightclub in
jacksonville
that makes sense um what's going on alex
moody how you going
i'm good man how are you guys we're
doing well sorry for that you're sorry
to
listen to us uh you have ufc parties man
how are you doing it yeah how do you do
it
i like doing get too annoyed at
hearing other people's opinions about
[ __ ] and i'm not a big drinker so
whenever i watch i'll have a little bit
of whiskey and enjoy it by myself
with me okay you like that diamond with
you you like that dime with you
now does your girl know about the fights
or do you squeeze her kind of hard when
she asks some questions
i gotta yeah i gotta let her know about
it because she's not really too into it
so i gotta because i do jiu jitsu and uh
muay thai or whatever so
i'll wrap her up in a little sipo or
whatever once in a while hell yeah dog
she don't like it too much from that
hard scarf dog if she knows what's good
for put her in that hs
dog sometimes you have to
i'll choke that [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
what i'm saying huh
make a sound for us make a japanese
sound chen
you can do a japanese sound we can do
japanese
[Laughter]
yeah but i'm saying you gotta freaking
wrap wrapping that hard scarf dude
america's favorite neckwear baby you
feel me let's go
i'm with you though man watch it by
yourself in the dark yeah man i'm gonna
send you also we got a new hard scarf
t-shirt man i'm gonna send you one of
them bro so you can freaking rep that
it's not even out yet i appreciate it
she could next time you at least you had
advertising if you guys have to go to
court with you and your lady at least
you could show up with that shirt yeah
she knows what's up yeah she knows what
she knows what she's getting into yeah
are you still a wipeout would you well
well
yeah i'm a green belt now but i started
striking i started boxing or whatever
but green belt it's like it's white belt
the same [ __ ] oh god
i'll do the naga thing i was gonna make
my amateur kickboxing debut last year
and then
about seven weeks before the fight broke
my arm and sparring
so yeah about to go make my debut in
about two months or whatever i'm gonna
do a little grappling tournament before
and then oh good luck man
yeah good luck out there dude so what's
up what's the king that are stinging
what do you got
watching ufc with friends or not doug oh
i like to watch it
you know if it's a i like to watch it
by myself i think or just with like one
or two people i don't
actually we had fun whenever we went
watch it at gianni's place that time
that was fun
if you have the right crew it's fun
there's good food
people know we're there to watch the
fights not do a [ __ ] podcast and talk
the whole time
yeah johnny invited me one time to
somebody's backyard somewhere and it was
like
really questionable dude that was kind
of scary but
another time we watched it like in a fun
spot i watched the chandler fight and
the dust and fight it like a bar it was
that was pretty funny because this is
the right vibe it's a good time
yeah yeah yeah i'm with you man by
myself drink a little whiskey with my
girl
i like watching them at home you know
nick and i watched that jon jones fight
one time
after that uh cattle racing or whatever
we went to remember
oh yeah oh yeah we went uh we we saw pbr
at the stable center and then we went
across the street and saw jon jones
was volkov no reyes sounds like a gay
night
i uh pretty good i've been watching
pretty good i've been watching
in the green room by myself really yeah
because i get off late so i just see
like the last three fights
but yeah man uh i don't know i think it
just depends but i
i understand wanting to watch it by
yourself sometimes people get so
personal with the
with the are attached so much to the
sport they really just want to be able
to see it all and not be interrupted you
know uh
i mean it's martial arts you know they
say arts in it because it has
you know this artistic side but it's
also like if if you want to see a dope
ass movie like say you rent a movie at
home i don't need everybody's [ __ ]
opinions on the guys acting
i'm just trying to watch the goddamn
movie dude same with fighting
unless you've been in there even if
you've been in there shut the [ __ ] up
man
yeah i don't want to see some drunk come
over and ask me a bunch of questions
either that's the worst thing like
talking about other stuff like or
somebody bugging you yeah
you know somebody punches their
girlfriend because they can't handle the
excitement all that kind of stuff you
know i don't know that's too much
confusion at a bar
good food a good fight at home nothing
better man yeah
and i like to watch indoors too yep
indoors only
good question brother have fun this
weekend man hopefully you're not around
a bunch of slap dicks
oh hell no hell no all right ty asked
one more question
um why do you guys uh do you guys not
like like or why is the
uh florida comedy scene seem bad i'm
born and raised in orlando
my whole life and i'm i just saw brian
count with improv a couple months ago
i'm just curious
that's why i'm joking
ryan cowan's extremely hilarious and i'm
just joking and no the florida scene's
actually pretty good
like i was just in naples last week uh
tampa's dope orlando was good they got
fort lauderdale miami there's a ton of
spots there the palm beach improv
it's good there's just i don't know what
it is you know it's just not like other
cities i don't i don't know why man
well florida's a state first of all and
i want an armored challenge no i'm
saying those cities
it's like something especially miami
there's like so much going on
but they're good crowds yeah you guys
just get a bad rap
yeah i think there's just so much going
on in florida there's crime
there's pirates there's uh first 48
there's
48 more murders there's alligator
there's cocaine it's baby at the disney
world
there's disney world there's orlando
there's universal studios there's just
so much
tampa bay buccaneers got tom brady up
the street yeah some of my favorite
comedians have come out of florida
though some great guys
yup daniel tosh eric myers r.i.p um
who else was out of there's tons of guys
out of florida uh
is there tons yeah who's that uh latino
guy
uh fluffy no no not fluffy
um [ __ ] i can't remember him it's all
good yeah daniel tosh is from there and
he represents pretty hard
yeah so i think it's got a good scene i
think it there's a lot of places that
comedians can drive through drive up and
down that coast and hit spot
there's a ton of spots out there yeah i
think orlando is just a weird place in
general it's almost like the bermuda
triangle but it's on the land
you know so it's it's such a diverse
city
so bizarre race wars every [ __ ]
corner
let's go let's go stay strapped dawg
that's all you can do dude
keep learning the martial arts man yup
learning martial arts man
good questions though brother appreciate
it man good luck with your tournament
yeah i appreciate you guys thank you for
all you do yeah praise brother
brother man i like that kid man is that
it nick
that's it i feel bad i ate some i tried
to bite part of my fingernails
oh that hurts and you ripped skin yeah i
don't know
it's the thing where i know in an hour
it's going to hurt me too [ __ ] it
makes me so mad
brendan i hate my nails are a nightmare
it makes me so
i buy them when i'm stressed dude what's
wrong with yours
yeah i don't have any nails oh i know my
god
i know dude those look like they were my
thumb dude
i know look what you do to him they
stress me out
yeah yeah well look what you just did to
me this big piece
and i needed this this is that when you
get into bread or something
yeah we get in the bread almost like
i got hawaiian bread you bite like yeah
when i rip open a croissant i'm not
gonna have that freaking outside
pressure get a little salt in there yeah
yeah dude
i'm just not gonna have the i just can't
get that angle good luck eating barbecue
daddy ugh
that petunia pete's or whatever not good
man well that's that's that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's that's that's that's that's the
one had a population of four
twenty seven hundred people yeah yeah
twenty four hundred oh yeah petunias we
didn't leave our yelp review
oh let's go there let's see she's gonna
send us some shirts too
yeah you get your sizes after the show
we'll have to buy some we'll start you
off let's see if we can get some of the
hormones that they got that as animals
on too and get them into your butt
uh yeah i almost said lelp review for
the yelp review what are you gonna leave
say uh some of the best barbecue ever
had a little chatty though
we know what it's our first one we only
i don't think anything negative
okay you guys are lame yeah i am
probably pretty pretty lame i'll agree
to that
but i would say all women's barbecue man
that's the first of a kind
all women's barbecue let's see what
these [ __ ] want from a n-word
like they say in that song dmx what
these [ __ ] want from what these
[ __ ] want
yeah and then we have to hush yep
i'm not eligible to sign up for you yeah
yeah
and that's a personal issue
yelp anymore i'm gonna do it on my own
time yeah
yeah i'm sure he will
yeah doing time is something nick's good
at okay
that's it man love seeing you brother
yeah i love seeing you two man gang gang
gang i'm in lexington kentucky
may 6th through the 8th and then houston
texas
may 20th through the 22nd get your
tickets coming strong
and i'm going to be in uh it looks like
i'm gonna be you can go to theovon.com
tour i'm gonna be in north carolina
minnesota baltimore and buffalo
um there should be some new tour dates
that are up uh
and that's it man that's it man i love
you guys
[Music]
i'm ready to go i need a sponsor i am a
monster about to open up with this at my
concerts flow is contagious browser
outrageous thicker than girls that are
instagram famous damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ate the queso and the quesoritos
but everything's gonna be fine hate on
me i do not mind theo looking like the
type of dude that got a pack of matches
in his pockets at all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want the smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brandon's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
oh yeah king and the sting beast
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you